the whole new world that Disney's
live-action Aladdin will take viewers to
is apparently the uncanny valley just
outside of bizarro town when the house
of mouse unveiled the second sneak peek
at this year's Aladdin Will Smith was
finally revealed as the genie I think
yes people are gonna love it the
extended look dropped as a surprise
during the 2019 Grammys On February 10th
and it was only a matter of minutes
before the internet lit a flame with
reactions people knew it was coming but
nothing could prepare the world for what
went down in the newest Aladdin trailer
you really don't know who I am
genie wishes land none at I ring it
above response to the new blue Genie has
been intense with countless people
reacting in horror blaming Smith's look
drawing comparisons between his
character and other blue dudes from pop
culture and slamming the live action
Aladdin as a waste of money
Josh bill incentive the Independent
Journal review wrote damn it James
Cameron no one asked for more avatar
movies
Kyle Buchanan of the New York Times was
downright horrified at the vision of
Smith as the genie tweeting they
premiered this image at night we are
supposed to sleep after this I have
never known peace Buchanan went on to
admit that his terror slowly turned to
twisted fascination writing the Will
Smith genie makes me feel the same way I
feel when a celebrity dies nauseous sad
and like I can't wait to tell everybody
about it did I scream yes a my pacing my
house now
uh-huh but am I also filled with
admiration the Aladdin movie is batting
in the big leagues now there are no
other movies until this one and there
may be no other movies after even joke
that Smith is the genie is what the
never shown on screen monsters of
Netflix's Bird box actually looked like
posting honestly the Will Smith genie
feels like a spoiler for Byrd box
because I finally understand what image
would make them so fascinated but also
want to kill themselves I just stepped
outside in power the no crashed cars how
are there not people walking around in a
daze have they not seen the Will Smith
genie yet dare I show them
[Music]
you tuber Jenny Nicholson shared the
same kind of guttural reaction to
Smith's blue Jeannie tweeting Will Smith
Jeannie is what appears in my room when
I have sleep paralysis writer and
comedian Mike Drucker equipped via
Twitter this looks like the last
character you unlock in a Final Fantasy
game and you rarely use him because
you've already leveled up the rest of
your party he then offered a chuckle
worthy juxtaposition of Smith's take on
the Jeannie
next to Arnold Schwarzenegger is mr.
freeze from 1997 s Batman and Robin
captioning the photoset me when mom says
I can have the house to myself versus
when mom comes home early
other reactions to Smith's Genie include
the many comparisons made to a smurf
David crosses Arrested Development
character Tobias bok and his Blue Man
Group audition get up egg Dwayne the
rock Johnson Scorpion King from the
mummy - I'm afraid I just blew myself
maybe you're one of the seemingly very
few people who think Smith looks great
as the genie or you're indifferent
because Genie already looked weird in
the original Aladdin because he's a
genie or you're dismayed at the fact
that your children will probably
recognize Smith's take on the character
before they ever recall Robin Williams's
og version you're a lot smaller than my
last master either that or I'm getting
bigger look at me from the side do I
look different to you either way there
is no avoiding the inevitable miss miss
Genie will burst out of the magic lamp
on the live action Aladdin soon enough
no matter if you find him shining
shimmering and splendid or a thing of
actual nightmares
Aladdin opens in theaters May 24th I was
terrified doing the genie you know after
Robin Williams but you know I found a
lane that you know pays be your age but
it's my own thing check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]